one of the world's most important
observatories that tries to solve some
of the mysteries of the universe is now
trying to solve a mystery of its own
why did a thick steel cable suddenly
snap
damaging a key instrument the arecibo
radio telescope in puerto rico
is now silent as a result
[Music]
it's been a backdrop for hollywood films
like the 1997 sci-fi drama
contact beauty
[Music]
it'll do
[Music]
and it's where james bond stopped the
villain in the climactic scene of
goldeneye
but puerto rico's arecibo observatory is
more than just a scene stealer
it's home to one of the world's largest
radio telescopes
acting as a giant ear to our universe
until this week
on monday morning the facility was
forced to close down after a cable
supporting a metal platform above the
telescope fell
tearing a 100 foot long gash in the
giant reflector dish
the cable didn't really break in the
sense of a cable kind of snapping
but it just sort of slipped from its
socket which is an even weirder
condition so we're still trying to get
our engineering team to make assessments
of that to understand the
the root cause the telescope located in
the middle of a forest
listens for radio signals from galaxies
near and far
it's contributed to numerous
breakthroughs in astronomy
and played a major role in the seti
program the search for intelligent life
even used by famed cornell astronomer
carl sagan to send an interstellar
message
but now radio communication both
incoming and outgoing
will be silent for a while observatory
technicians have been working around the
clock trying to get the telescope back
online but it probably won't be a quick
fix
we still don't know we're still making
assessments trying to understand really
what caused the failure making sure that
we're storing the structural
capabilities so at this point we don't
really have a clear timeline when that
is going to happen
since it was built in 1963 the
observatory has survived
terrestrial hazards like hurricanes
tropical storms and
earthquakes but it is other worldly
threats the telescope is on the lookout
for
tracking asteroids that could endanger
our planets it's also been part of the
search for other planets that
may be able to sustain life all reasons
why the scientific community
hopes it is back up and running soon
we'll find a way to repair
uh this particular issue and continue to
move forward we've overcome a lot
in our 50-year history from hurricane
maria to a very recent rash of
earthquakes to now this so we're
resilient punch down here and we're
gonna figure out a way to continue to
move forward doing exciting science for
the world
one of those places you haven't heard of
but you've seen before and you know it
as soon as you
exactly watch it on camera there yeah
i'm just so important i'm glad that
there are people that are much smarter
than i am
yes indeed that's exactly right
yeah carl sagan opened my eyes to seti
and certainly in contact the movie
it was a joy to see it's gorgeous i hope
they do get it fixed